[Musique]
c'est déjà
quelque chose d'assez
en tout cas extraordinaire pour moi
d'être déjà de retour sur les terrains
de retour à l'entraînement est de
pouvoir déjà être en compétition c'est
vrai que c'est arrivé trop vite
oui je suis content d'être de retour
j'arrive pas à écorner en même temps ok
mais c'est pas c'est pas une fin en soi
et qu'il ya encore tellement travail
il ya tellement de choses voilà
améliorer et progresser pour ne
serait-ce pour remporter un 5e match
le chemin est encore très long mais on
entend la motivation est là l'envié est
là donc
donc voilà je suis content d
déjà jouer quelques tournois sur cette
année le rythme
[Musique]
il
quoique j'ai joué ici on m'a dit l'aïe a
17 ans et me dire qu'on revient sur un
endroit 17 ans après donc c'est vraiment
s'agit pas s'user l'impression de
vraiment très très bien et maintenant
mais oui c'est le tableau est déjà très
relevé c'est vrai que l'on joue des
tours aux décideurs du sort pour gagner
des points pour essayer de la gagner des
matches et progresser au classement mais
c'est vrai que lorsqu'il ya un tableau
où tu as des joueurs dans le top 100
tout de suite c'est savoir le gentil peu
plus difficile mais d'un côté je
m'inspire à sentir le but est de
retrouver
le plus haut niveau et ça passe par
voilà je mets contre contre les
meilleurs et c'est vrai que ce tome à
poitiers en fin d'année très très court
il n'y a que des bonnes manches
[Musique]